gelée je lui dis en temps il arrive il
va faire une de ses têtes
telle est l'idée franchement je
préfèrerais que ce soit toi bon ben je
vais prendre mon courage à deux mains
sales jolie salut françois salut casimir
dont joueurs casimir
je suis en pleine forme et j'ai plein
d'idées pour passer une journée
formidable aujourd'hui justement casimir
je vais te dire que j'ai produit au
maire attend dé nous dit rien je vais
d'abord vous raconter tout ce que j'veux
qu'on fait les nazis mais attend sa
tante
d'abord je vais aller dans le petit bois
pour cueillir des mûres quasi mais
ensuite je viendrai tranquillement
déguster ses murs
sous un grand arbre mais on en écoutant
les histoires que l'on raconte mes amis
les oiseaux
lorsqu'il vole très haut près des nuages
et que témoin casimir jégourel ce n'est
pas tout ensuite j'irai un long moment
regardez les nouvelles acrobaties qu'on
préparait spécialement pour moi mes amis
de la famille la roja par kasimi même si
j'aurai largement le temps de tout faire
je compte même ensuite aller dire
bonjour à monsieur beauchesne casimir
maintenant ça suffit
mais qu'est ce qui t'arrive à beaucoup
de casimir du nous laisse même pas
placer une parole
je pensais que vous le meilleur ami vous
seriez content de savoir ce que j'allais
faire par une si belle journée oui en
temps normal mais oui aujourd'hui nous
avons ici tout est impossible
qu'est-ce qui pourrait m'empêcher
d'aller dans le petit bois alors eh bien
voilà tenir là ce qui se passe oh non je
préfère que tu lis toi même la carte
postale que nous avons reçues tous les
trois requis report une carte postale
chic j'adore recevoir des cartes
postales surtout qu'on fait les enfants
qui m'écrivent à leur lit un bien un
mais très chères familles en ces gentils
cc pour nous allez continuez
très chers amis c'est une grande
surprise quand je vous annonce moi votre
ami ed mais [ __ ] mais c'est une
catastrophe une future à venir j'ai fini
la carte
là je viens vous rendre visite j'ai
quelques travaux à faire dans le petit
bois
j'espère que j'y rencontrais mon petit
colibri en sucre le petit colibri à
sucre un sétois n'ont enfin je n'ai
jamais été entendu brillant sucrant mais
malheureusement pour toi casimir c'est
ainsi que te voyais les futaies enfin
les complètement folle elle raconte
n'importe quoi
et elle change tout tendre à vie parce
que j'étais d'abord ça grenouille en
chocolat avant j'étais son petit canard
hon caramel c'est parce qu'elle a de
l'affection pour toi mais c'est
dramatique car je ne vais même pas
pouvoir aller m'amuser dans le petit
bois
casimir il ne te reste plus qu'à aller
te cacher chez toi tu
il m'a tout est rentré dans le port ya
10 minutes elle va arriver d'un instant
à l'autre on l'a mais l'aurait aimé mes
amis les lapins et les oiseaux qui
m'attendent ils vont être déçus et
présente la mademoiselle futé oui mais
c'est impossible elle serait capable de
les emmener cependant il faut que je
trouve une autre idée casimir qui s'est
mis mon vieux dépêche toi t'es belle
choix possible voici un petit cache toi
qu'est ce soir quand vous bonjour les
amis c'est très beau voyage comme
d'habitude marcano près de votre île je
viens lagast et sans nous la paix c'est
que je viens de me coincer là le doigt
dans la porte du kiosque pour
jour quand même enfin selon nous la main
c'est à dire que quand vous refusez de
mesure de la main aux non non non non
non mais je me suis tordu le poignet
alors comme vous oui je sais je n'aime
pas les poignées damas moi je ne vois
pas casimir haras je sais pas où il est
passé
mais mais c'est drôle mais il était là
il ya un moment non non non je ne suis
pas là je suis parti très loin ou mais
j'ai entendu sa voix vous êtes sucre moi
j'ai rien remarqué mais je vous assure
que je ne suis pas là haut mais le pana
montana je vous assure je ne suis pas
votre canard oui allons mais attends moi
mon petit poussin rose
tu vas venir avec moi ta grande amie est
demandée par épandage de lait me fait
quelque chose pour quelque chose
quasiment à l'air élémentaire volet non
j'ai laissé site extrêmement délicat du
compromis
mademoiselle fuite est une personne
extrêmement sympathique et leur propose
lui de tape de la compagnie mouah ah non
non non non jamais je cherchais quelque
chose d'urgent faire il faut que j'aille
chez le médecin oui depuis hier j'ai une
rig entend pas très bien montée c'était
des filets en tout cas tu vas donner une
bonne idée pour sauver casimir casini
qu'est-ce que ça pour tout ce monde
magique où tout pousse
viens vite c'est l'heure de tout rendez
vous chez le médecin qui me tient mais
qu'est-ce que jamais
tu as mal aux oreilles enfin non mais
qu'est ce qui laisse aux pauvres passent
en bleu il a mal aux oreilles où on
accueille alors je ne sais pas je n'en
ai pas les situe en amidon meeddat
inquiète pas ta grande amie de mme eva
temps est le même chez le médecin ou non
mais je peux très bien y aller tout seul
je vous remercie non je ne voudrais pas
vous empêcher de visiter le petit bois
non mais non mais non mais ça fait rien
je ne veux pas y aller écouter jean un
sourd aux voiles à monsieur lui sinon
monsieur du snop à vous accompagner au
mieux ça doit être ça me fait très
occupé et puis nous n'avons jamais été
présentée non mais je vais tout arranger
monsieur du cinoche occasion leur donne
moi je suis très pris attendez attendez
il ya là mademoiselle futile je n'ai pas
été présentés à cette personne à 8 c est
une personne qui va prendre le thé tous
les jours chez les contextes et qu'elle
voudrait que vous l'accompagnez mais
bien volontiers présentement tout de
suite voix nyon dont ma très chère amie
manceau un elfe y était je présume
espoirs messieurs 10 nov
c'est bon nous la main vos lentilles
rennes moselle futé n'aime pas les
poignées de main molle je m'en suis
rendu compte
monsieur du snob veux bien vous
accompagner
il est trop mignon 7,1 millions d'euros
caramel mai mais voyons aussi les maçons
on revoit les pays bas sont jaunes bonne
promenade casimir
[Musique]